my name is
Alton my title is the president under
derp the Woodrow Wilson international
center for scholars in Washington I'm
also the director of the center on
Congress at Indiana University and I
prefer to be called Lee
I'm not sure quite what impact it had on
me I remember very clearly my father
coming into the room and saying the
Japanese at bombed Pearl Harbor I really
had no concept of the seriousness of
that but I could tell from my father's
demeanor that he was very worried about
it and so I guess I was worried too so I
grew up at a time when the country was
going through an economic depression in
the 30s then shifted to a war footing
with very rapid changes in American
society I'm sure I didn't understand all
of that but that was the Maloo in which
I grow up I then moved to Evansville
Indiana and i think i was in the seventh
or eighth grade when that occurred and
from that point on my recollections
Arlen clear and it's very simple
basketball I grew up in an environment
very similar to the movie Hoosiers in my
sole focus in the early days of my life
was basketball
well I'm a great believer in athletics
and I'm a great believer in competitive
athletics I have no doubt at all that my
competitive instincts started at a very
young age initially began in track and
field events then shifted to basketball
but from the earliest that I can
remember second third grade I wanted to
be the fastest runner in the class I was
not very much interested in the
classroom my teachers would often say
that my only interest in life was the
playground and the playground activities
that competitive instinct was just in
eight from the very beginning and it's
certainly sharpened in my basketball
years I got an awful lot out of
basketball the coaches were just
terrific and gave me a lot of guidance
and direction made sure I didn't go
australia i guess and impressed upon me
the importance of working together
cooperation team spirit if you will
lessons that i think i hope i've carried
with me through my life
one of my very vivid recollections is
walking across the stage at the
commencement of depaul university in
greencastle indiana to receive my
undergraduate degree and thinking very
clearly to myself I didn't have a
slightest idea of what I wanted to do
and being quite envious really of my
fellow students who seemed to have a
much more directed focused life than I
did I traveled a year in Europe I
enrolled at a university there a goethe
university frankfurt on mine but didn't
really study very much first time had
ever been to Europe I began then to
develop an interest in government and
politics I guess just from reading the
newspapers I came back and I went to law
school I thought I would practice law
and I did for a period of time but to be
blunt about it i was bored by it i went
to a chicago firm marvelous lawyers good
people but i I just was not engaged and
I decided well I'd go back and practice
law in Indiana I enjoyed it more county
seat practice a lot of contact with
clients tried a lot of cases but even
then I had a certain restlessness and I
said well I'll give politics a try and I
did and I enjoyed it I can't identify
any single point where I suddenly said
well I'm going to go into politics and
make that my calling but it grew over a
period of years after really I left
college
you